i could eat
could you eat because i could always eat
here's something
to hold this over hi drew i'm capri lily
creator of good food batty to make this
pumpkin spice latte first we're going to
start with pumpkin puree about a
tablespoon and then we're going to
sweeten the latte with a couple
teaspoons of maple syrup
now we're going to add just a bit of
vanilla extract and
now adding pumpkin spice and now i'm
adding the espresso
the last ingredient to add is the milk i
like to use oat milk because it makes a
latte super creamy
now we'll just blend all the ingredients
together until it's nice and smooth
and that's it now you have this
delicious pumpkin spice latte
i like to finish my latte with some
whipped cream
and cinnamon hi drew this is emily i'm
going to show you how to make some
wholesome
cosmic brownies first you're going to
mix together a cup of almond butter
2 3 cups of coconut sugar a quarter cup
of maple syrup
two flax eggs or regular eggs if you're
not vegan
and a teaspoon of vanilla extract stir
it all up then add in a third cup of
cacao powder
a tablespoon of coconut flour half a
teaspoon baking soda and a quarter
teaspoon of salt
it's going to be really thick but don't
worry that's what makes these super
fudgey
bake them at 350 for about 24 minutes
and while those are cooking let's make
our ganache
mix together a half a cup of melted
coconut oil a third cup of canned
coconut milk
half a cup of maple syrup and then a
half cup plus a third cup of cacao
powder
you can leave it thick like this or melt
it add a little almond milk and pour it
over your cooled brownies
top it with some fun sprinkles if you
want and enjoy
today i'm going to teach you how to make
these cute little monster cupcakes using
our classic vanilla cupcake recipe
first step is to take about a tablespoon
of the black buttercream and smear it
across half of your cupcake
then using white buttercream with the
number four tip in your pastry bag
you're going to add the teeth i already
added a few here so we'll just do the
last couple
and you really can't mess this up just
do anything that's kind of scary looking
then using a number 133 tip you're going
to add the hair
i love it in the color purple but you
could use any color you want
and just kind of wiggle it around until
it looks nice and full
and scary and then the last step
is you're going to add a couple of
eyeballs these are edible candies
and just place them across the top of
your cupcake you can find the vanilla
cupcake recipe and 150
other foolproof recipes in my new book
the magnolia bakery handbook thank you
hi drew this is emily from wholesome
hiddenista and today we're going to make
a flowerless death by chocolate mug cake
filled with raspberries
start off with two tablespoons of cacao
powder or cocoa powder
a tablespoon of coconut flour a quarter
teaspoon of baking soda
and an eighth of a teaspoon of salt give
that a really good stir
and add in a quarter cup of canned
pumpkin
two tablespoons of maple syrup
a tablespoon of whatever nut butter you
like i used almond butter
and a half of a teaspoon of vanilla
give that a really good stir making sure
to get all the dry bits at the bottom
and add in a tablespoon of chocolate
chips if you like and microwave for a
minute and 30 seconds
fill with maple syrup sweetened
raspberries or enjoy plain
hi drew this is vivian aaronson
cookingbong from tick-tock
today i'm going to make glow-in-the-dark
raindrop cake
perfect for halloween little scary but
until i turn off lights
so first we boil 320 ml of water
then add two tablespoons condensed
coconut milk
now we add a half teaspoon this agar
agar powder
here is the secret ingredient to glue in
a dark vitamin b2
like a half capsule powder in here so
everything dissolves
let it cool a little bit for the in the
mold
put the top on chill in the fridge for
two hours
ring drop cake from the mold let's turn
off lights
everything glow so now you can make your
favorite cocktail then
put the ring drop cake in your drink
cheers
happy halloween today we are going to
make apple butter
apple butter is a rich sweet spread
that's basically a concentrated
more flavorful applesauce all we need
are some fresh apples
cored and diced and we're going to throw
those in a saucepan with a pinch of salt
some cinnamon cloves a splash of lemon
juice and some maple syrup
stir everything up cover our pot and
cook over low heat for about two hours
until the apples are nice and soft then
we'll use our immersion blender to puree
the apple mixture until it's nice and
smooth
enjoy hi drew this is jay cohen and i'm
here to share my apples and honey snack
and cake recipe
you're going to start by browning one
stick of butter on the stove top throw
it into a heat proof bowl and add in a
half a cup of olive oil
for our sweeteners one cup of granulated
sugar and a half a cup of honey
throw in three quarters cup of
applesauce for moisture one teaspoon of
vanilla extract and
two eggs we're gonna give our wet a good
old mix for our dry
teaspoon of cinnamon nutmeg kosher salt
and a half teaspoon of baking powder and
baking soda
throw that in with two and a quarter
cups of all-purpose flour
fold to combine then chop up two honey
crisp apples into
half-inch chunks and get that into the
batter once that's all combined i'm
gonna throw this into a greased and
parchment lined
eight-inch square baking dish bake this
at 350 for about 40 to 45 minutes just
until a toothpick stuck in the center
comes out clean
let it cool make it rain powdered sugar
and cut yourself a big
old slice
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
today i'm going to show you how to make
a healthy dairy free pumpkin spice soft
serve
start off with one can of full fat
coconut milk half a cup of pumpkin puree
a third of a cup of maple syrup one
teaspoon of pumpkin pie spice
a half a teaspoon of vanilla and two
tablespoons of our almond butter
then you're going to blend that up in a
high-powered blender until just combined
and then transfer it to an ice cream
machine or pour into ice cube trays
freeze overnight and then blend in a
high-powered blender or food processor
until
thick smooth and creamy i like to top
mine with some extra
pumpkin pie spice and some coconut
whipped cream
i hope you enjoy yum i cannot wait to
eat that